hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer questions
from one of my four meters Anthony who
is asking about Twitter and how to
generate sales leads through it and if
it's worth following people who are
potential customers if that's the best
way to get leads through Twitter so I
think there's a number of the poise use
Twitter and the two main ways are either
push or pull so I prefer to use the pull
method and that's basically where you're
posting value add content so people want
to follow you so I don't know what your
Nisha is or who your target market is
for me it's entrepreneurs so if you
follow my twitter feed you'll see that
i'm talking about entrepreneurship
strategies that I find interesting
things that keep me motivated and
hopefully is enough to inspire people to
then want to follow my stream so you
provoke you're providing value ID
information that people who are your
potential customers want to learn more
about you want to follow and it is a
slow build they'll find you through
search to find you through you know
people who are retweeting you they can
find you through your website they can
follow you there you put it in your
email and basically you're getting
people to start to follow you based on
the content you're providing so you're
not pushing out no you need to buy for
me right now you're not being a hard
sale there you're providing value you
get to be seen as the expert for you
industry and people start to contact you
and want to follow you and that's the
method I use and it's been pretty
successful but it's not the only way to
do it so that's the pole method the push
method is when you're actually going out
and trying to initiate contact with your
potential customers and there's a couple
ways to do this the first is to just
start building our relationship and
these can be with high value prospects
that you think could really make a
difference for your business so you
follow them you get to know them you
comment on them you talk about some of
the posts that they're doing you give
them some retweets you provide your
opinion if you do it a couple times
people start to take notice and I notice
it for mine too and people interact with
my tweets and they write back or they
retweeted it what happens enough then I
start to notice who's doing it and I'll
check out their site now check out their
twitter feed and i might contact them
it's a good way to get on somebody's
radar so if you have some ideal
prospects that you're going after you
can start interacting
so you're not pitching them you're not
selling them you're just starting to
build a relationship and get them to
know about you so that's one way it's a
little bit slower build but it's better
for kind of the high-value prospects for
the other ones if you are trying to make
a quick sale then you can look for
people who have you know certain issues
are posting about it on Twitter I have a
problem with XYZ and you can say that
you can help them solve it so it's more
of a hard sale approach I don't know how
effective it is I think if somebody's
really having a problem then you might
be able to get in there and provide a
solution as long as you are you know
friendly and genuine and they think that
you can really help them it's not really
the method that I prefer using again I
go for more for the pole strategy and
maybe a couple people if I'm really want
to get on their radar I could use that
you know strategy of just following them
and getting to know them I think it's a
more effective strategy for you to use
on Twitter but it's a longer term build
so you're not going to get sales
tomorrow for your company doing it but
it is a longer-term build and it is
highly effective in your building
relationships and that's where I think
you would have the most effect with your
business try it out see what works for
you I'd love to hear what everybody else
is doing for Twitter what strategies are
working and what aren't working if you
want to leave a comment under the video
please feel free to share those and if
you like the video please give it a
thumbs up I always love seeing those
commensal thank you and we'll see you on
the next episode
you